الكثير من المراحل تمر بها طائره عملاقه
مثل طائره اي 330 ام ار تي تي هذه هي
واحده من هذه المراحل دعونا نتعرف بشكل
اكبر على المراحل التي تتم بها تصنيع
طائره اي 330 ام ار تي تي من السيد توماس
وهو رئيس انتاج طائرات اي 330 ام ار تي تي
اولا مصر توماس اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتانيا في البدايه دعنا نتعرف بشكل
مبسط على المراحل التي تمر بها طائره اي
330 ام ار تي تي سواء في التصنيع وكذلك
فيما يتعلق بالمصنع هل لديكم وحدات انتاج
جديده وما هي كذلك ابرز هذه الوحدات
بشكل اساسي هذا ليس خط التجميع النهائي بل
هو مركز تحويله نحن نستلم الطائره خضراء
قادمه من تولوز ونبدا بعدها عمليه التحويل
الاعداد الصناعي هو كالتالي لدينا ثلاث
حظائر نقوم في المحطه الاولى بالتعديلات
الهيكليه وتركيب القطع الكبير والالواح ثم
النظام وبعد ذلك تركيب الاسلاك من اجل
اعداد الطائره وفي هذه المرحله يجب ان
تكون الطائره معلقه بسبب الشد الكبير على
الهيكله اما المرحله الثانيه فتشمل قلب
عمليه التحويل كما نرى هنا في هذه المحطه
وما نقوم به في هذه المرحله هو تركيب نظام
والاسلاك والقطاع والجهاز الاساسي لقدرات
التزود بالوقود جوانا وكذلك محطه المشغل
حيث يتمكن مشغل اعاده التعبئه بالوقود جوا
من توجيه الخرطوم جوا لتعب الوقود بنجاح
وبعد ذلك ننتقل الى الاختبار الارضي
الداخلي والخارجي قبل ان نذهب الى خط
الطيران واجراء اختبارات الطيران ثم تسليم
الطائرات الى العميل مصر
بالمهمه الواحده كم طائره تستطيع طائره ام
ار تي تي ان تزودها بالوقود خلال المهمه
الواحده وكذلك ما هي نوعيه هذه الطائرات
وهل لديها القدره على التكيف مع كافه
انواع الطائرات والمقاتلات
جدا لانها تعتمد على نوع المهمه التي يرغب
العميل بادائها المهمه النموذجيه قد تشمل
اربع طائرات في مهمه اعاده التعبئه
بالوقود الى جانب طائره ام ار تي تي ومره
اخرى الامر يعتمد بشكل كبير على الوقود
داخل الطائره لدينا سعه 110 اطنان من
الوقود كما تعتمد على المسافه التي يجب ان
تقطعها من اجل تزويد الوقود كان هناك حديث
انه حدث مشكلات فيما يت تزويد مقاتلات او
طرازات محدده من مقاتلات اف 15 حدث هذا في
استراليا وكذلك في الولايات المتحده كيف
تعاملت مع هذا الامر وبالتالي هل نحن الان
نستطيع ان نقول بان طائره ام ار تي ليس
لديها مشكله فيما يتعلق بتزويد اي طائره
في الجو بالوقود
[موسيقى]
الريفيولنج
في الحقيقه فانا اعاده تعبئه تعمل مع
تشكيله مختلفه من الطائرات وبشكل اساسي مع
جميع الطائرات سواء المقاتله او طائرات
النقل وكل عملياتنا مرخصه وعندما قمنا
بترخيص التعبئه الاوتوماتيكيه مع 16
وطائرات الاكبر فان الخطوه التاليه ستشمل
اف 15 ايضا
فيما يتعلق بالمستقبل الان هناك شركات
تعمل على انتاج مسيرات تعمل على تزويد
الطائرات بالوقود في الجو فيما يتعلقتكم
هنا في التصنيع داخل ايرباص ما هي هذه
الخطه وكذلك ما هو شكل المستقبل بالنسبه
نحن نسعى لتطوير قدراتنا بشكل مستمر
ومؤخرا تمكنا من ترخيص اي 3 ار وتزويدها
بقدرات التزويد الاوتوماتيكي بالوقود جون
والخطوه التاليه التي نفكر فيها بعد ذلك
هي اعاده تعبئه الذاتيه التي تمكن طائره
المزوده للوقود بالتحكم بالطائره
المستقبله